portes Department of calendars looking
into claims that a Gulf Coast school
made hundreds of people sick from
diseases like cancer health officials
are asking alumni and faculty of the
school affected by cancer to submit
their health records so far the
department says there's no evidence
Bayshore High School is the source of
any disease clusters and well pahor
'kiss is in Bradenton Florida south of
Tampa where some community members say
the evidence is clear and well good
morning good morning this is where
Bayshore High School stood it was torn
down in the late 90s in place of a
bigger campus next door but suspicions
about health problems linking back to
the old property have been around for
decades
last week the school district mailed
these forms to thousands of former
students asking anyone who's become sick
to tell their stories I can't look at a
yearbook I don't see classmates I see
victims Sheryl josa graduated from Bay
Shore High School in 1981 two years
after her older sister Terri in 1999
doctors diagnosed Terri with a rare type
of leukemia she died six months later a
few years after her sister's death josa
learned another Bay Shore classmate had
also died of leukemia she said a light
went off in her head you would talk to
this person they would say well
so-and-so sister died of you know
leukemia the numbers that I have
recorded are from word-of-mouth by
speaking to people people writing to me
Joseph's believes the cases at Bay Shore
constitute a cancer cluster my sister's
class of 235 we have four leukemias
recorded on three of those have passed
away the CDC defines a cancer cluster as
a greater than expected number of cancer
cases that occurs within a group of
people in a geographic area over a
period of time over the last 13 years
Joseph says she has tracked nearly 500
cases linking Bay Shore alumni and
employees to cancer autoimmune diseases
or children with birth defects it is
very daunting to find the smoking gun or
the cause of a cluster dr. Thomas Berke
teaches at Johns Hopkins Bloomberg
School of Public Health to define a
cancer cluster is you have
to be sure of the diagnosis of people
you have to be sure the number of cases
you have to look at the time involved
Papa Dulce was in Joseph's class doctors
found a tumor pressing on his spine in
April and diagnosed him with hairy cell
leukemia was an agriculture class and we
uh we grew strawberries out in the big
field and I ate those strawberries
played in the field I think there's a
good chance that it could have come from
you know something out of the ground but
years of soil and groundwater testing on
the school property have found no
significant contamination there was
contamination a mile away at an old
machine shop but the county believes it
did not impact the school Manatee County
and the school board have asked the
Health Department to survey alumni and
staff to determine whether a cluster
exists dr. diana green is the school
district superintendent the facts at
this point indicate over the last 15
years that location has been tested
numerous times and each time it comes
back with a negative indication related
to a possible cancer cluster this is a
picture of my son he would be 442 today
for community members and family of the
sick and dad the search for answers has
been long in 2014 of October I was
diagnosed with brain cancer stage 3
last April many voiced their frustration
at a County Commission meeting when this
is all said and done I mean they'll
they'll come up with their findings if
they don't necessarily reflect what you
believe do you keep going I will keep
going till we find out what it is we
have a right to know what we were
exposed to Cheryl says she suffers from
autoimmune diseases herself the Health
Department will stop collecting medical
information at the end of February it
will then be transferred over to the
University of Miami and results are
expected six months after that
Gail mystery they need to solve their
thank you very much Manuel